back to bill that's a quarter three and
the rebound out to harden harden lobs it
up house throws it down
no per 4 from the floor are the Wizards
to open up Brian there's the first field
goal of the game for the Wizards
not too sad that's inherited Arden got
himself in rhythm watch amaura back the
other way
has it swatted by capela really good
time about capela right there house the
corner three
Daniel how soft the feed by a photo game
because you don't want that to lead to
something else so they let them know
that they call them again close plenty
of time shot clock at seven veal against
house to the hoop and there's Beto with
a field goal and it's a six-point game a
16-2 for wizards run Hardin able to go
around and over vogner good pass by Beal
good roll there by mo when your
franchise guy business scoring the ball
immediately early in the first quarter
at amazing cliff they'll try to DT much
but I love bills approach still passing
the ball and being a discipline how
about that he saw no help went right to
the hoop and a timeout taken here by the
Rockets son Beal gets it back to hot
Jamar looking first first NBA three
there it is
team that hasn't been great from three
to start the year shooting about 50%
here in this game Bryant rolling great
hands and the finish Bradley Beal
recognizing Bryant drive it to the
basket
[Music]
he'll step-back jumper
that's good
pronounce your name he goes it's Isaac
and finally Tommy Shepard asked him and
he said my mom says Issa so he socket is
the socket is a mom would get salt into
judgment on that for 11 points feel
step-back jumper that's good
we talked about this Smith Bradley bill
there really are more peel off the
offensive rebound knocks down the three
nice deal for cash the extension
speaking of cash yeah harden draws the
contact against Brown he'll go to the
free-throw line and try to convert the
three-point play oh really wonder what a
championship
there's assists number 11 to his buddy
harden for the dunk and now beat playing
the safety able to knock it away Beal
for three yes and again a chance for the
Wizards to take the leap go two for one
that's what wheel is thinking and that's
what he does Jory Brown will inbound
gets it to Bryant to Beal
[Applause]
second straight quarter a buzzer-beater
for the Wizards practices the deflection
feel oh yeah it's good he's got 20
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hit his last nine field goal attempts
he's got 23 and it's a four-point lead
the alley-oop / capela trying to handle
that zip pass by Bryant could not
five-on-four for the Rockets pardon
against hot shamora harden got it and
the foul a small space gotta push you on
the eyelid zigzags get the car he gave a
lot of credit to rajon rondo
he said Rondo is like a coach out there
he made me watch film to understand how
the dorm guys like boy
you can't guard that right there off the
offensive rebound
you can slow him down he's unguardedly
do all the things that he'd bring to the
table offensive Jim Bradley peel answers
right back the tougher on them offensive
leads to keying in on him he's gonna
find a way because he's just that good
action Mora for three that's good his
second three going right to his spot and
shoes over two defenders he's putting on
the clinic Harden oh she's sick game of
horse right now going to the bottom half
of the fifth pardon he's got the contact
against Beal and he'll go to the
free-throw line and try to tie it up
bill look get a good job trying to beat
him to the spot probably got his hands
on it manga unhardened manga doing his
best to stay in front that's just not
fair it's 40 on the night now for Harden
Beal for three Bradley Beal ties it up
in the corner for three
Beal trying to get the rebound
he takes it away from house who slipped
in our house to Mitch the foul
[Applause]
bill against harden to Brian
Gabriel offensively going right at hard
wanted to the body of capella he's got
to be careful with those four fouls
against harden pardon he's at 49 now
seventh all time
long rebound harden to the corner
McLemore for three that's good
he was a huge pick up within this
offseason hadn't been McEvoy Johnson and
he's sixth all-time in Wizards history
for scoring loose ball rivers harden to
the hoop with the right and that puts
him at 51
Tamura against harden
harden for three
54 for hardened spiel against Tucker
going
real deal bradley field look at this
down he'll going off the glass and look
at the big what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content